okay fourth rule for debating frame the
debate properly so you see this all the
time people frame the debate completely
incorrectly so in every debate the left
is trying to frame the debate in a
particular way so let's take an example
from the last couple of weeks the left
was trying to frame this issue on the
border as Donald Trump is separating
children from their parents and the
Trump administration responded by saying
well the reason we're separating
children from their parents is because
it was a deterrent that was their
original response that is the worst
response ever all right that is a bad
response the way that they should have
responded is by saying that's the first
of all that's not true we don't want to
separate children from their parents the
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals rules
that if we arrest people we have to
separate children from their parents so
if you don't like that rule we go back
to the Obama era rule or we detain
everybody which is of course what Trump
is doing now right now Trump is said
okay we'll find won't detain everybody
and then the left goes well it's not see
ask when you separate parents and
children and it's not see escalate and
keep them together because their end
argument is they just want everybody
released but how you frame the debate
originally really matters in a major way
now President Trump actually is
typically very good at framing the
debate I mean President Trump actually
is great at picking a frame that works
for him and then moving on it so
instinctively he has a good feel for
this so on the immigration debate when
he says immediately Democrats won't open
borders that is a good way to frame the
debate because that is actually the
debate and Democrats don't want to have
that debate because they lose that
debate they want to have that you're
mean to kids debate the problem with
this latest rollout is that if they'd
rolled it out with you want open borders
we don't want open borders the reasons
parents are being separated from kids is
because that is the current law we'd
like the law to change and we're calling
on Congress to do so that would've been
the way to frame the debate totally
they're coming around to it it's just a
little bit late so it's all about
framing the debate when whenever you're
debating anybody and this is true for
any topic the left has its series of
frames on debate whenever they talk
about global warming for example they
will frame the debate as you don't care
whether there's global warming or you
are a global warming denier the way
should actually frame the debate is okay
what are your solutions to global
warming the reason being that I assume
that did there very few climate
scientists in the room I'm not a climate
scientist
I don't know that much about the the
reactivity of the atmosphere to carbon
emissions but even if I accept the IPCC
estimate that by the end of the century
the average climate across planet earth
will rise something on the order of
seven degrees Fahrenheit that does not
suggest that massive government
intervention ism is necessarily the fix
in fact it's pretty good shot that it's
not the facts considering that if the
Kyoto Protocol or the Paris Accords were
implemented right now it
barely lower the climate the temperature
at all according to their own best
estimates once you get into that the
last has nothing to say they'd prefer to
stick in the area where you're an
ignoramus who doesn't know anything
about science an you hate science so
it's all about reframing every debate
right and on abortion it's about not
argue about women's choice it's about
arguing whether this is a human life or
not because that really is the only
debate that matters right I'm not
against women's choice women can choose
to do whatever they want just they can't
kill babies because I can't kill babies
because no one can kill babies so it's
all about where you choose to frame the
debate